bonjour à tous c'est le major gérald
l'officier des sports du 1er régiment
étranger à aubagne on se donne rendez
vous ce matin pour un circuit
d'entraînement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la première vidéo qu'on a fait c'était
le grimper de corde pour les gens qui
n'y arrive pas voilà on part vraiment de
la base puisque nous on se dit bien que
les gens qui en comptera l'armée ne sont
pas déjà des supers commando il va
falloir les formes et les entraîner
accor
ça a généré du recrutement que des gens
se sont présentés à l'engagement et dans
le protocole de questions la question
posée est souvent sais comment que j'ai
connu la légion trop cher comment vous
avez entendu parler aux enchères et je
crois que c'est en 2021 près de huit
candidats sur disque au livre à sous
vidéo major général
[Musique]
on s'aperçut que c'était vraiment un
contenu pédagogique et les recrues ont
d'abord cherché à s'entraîner en
fonction de ce que proposait le major
gérald avant de venir sont engagés à la
légion étrangère ou pour nous c'est un
gain de temps au niveau de la formation
et c'est aussi ça on a vu la qualité des
personnes venant à l'engagement
s'améliorer
[Musique]